ich will dass sie nicht
dieser dom ist das wahrzeichen von
magdeburg die stadt liegt direkt an der
elbe und sie ist die vorletzte station
von team süd eigentlich hätten christina
jonas und nasa eine pause auf der
uferpromenade verdient aber kaum sind
sie auf dem markt um sich ein paar äpfel
zu kaufen wartet schon die nächste
aufgabe oder der einheimische eltern das
ist der beliebteste appell deutschland
nehmen wir ein kilo von heer und ein
kilo fertig sind zusammen 239 euro 61
finde das rezept für quarkkeulchen
herauskauft die zutaten und bereitete
zwölf stück zu mit quark
im teils in auggen quarkkeulchen sind
eine regionale spezialität aber in
magdeburg kennt offenbar keiner das
rezept gute idee hier gibt es bestimmt
kochbücher treffer die buchhändlerin
braucht gar kein kochbuch sie kennt das
rezept auswendig und zu den quark
reichen gibt es noch den passenden
nachtisch und dann gibt es dazu äpfel
mais und zucker und zimt
in einem bioladen kaufen die drei alle
zutaten mehl eier und besondere koppeln
wir brauchen
mehlig kochende
mehlig kochende kartoffeln werden beim
kochen weich das gegenteil sind
festkochende kartoffeln
team süd hat nun rezept und zutaten nur
noch bezahlen dann kann es losgehen
gleich um die ecke liegt das antik café
wo köchin carola wartet als erstes
kartoffeln schälen jonas und nasser auf
der einen seite köchin carola und
christina auf der anderen wechseln
spätestens jetzt zeigt sich wer von den
dreien öfter in der küche steht
nur wenn meine mutter nicht zu hause ist
dann muss ich auf jeden fall gruppen
das mag ich nicht im teig land mehl eier
kartoffeln quark rosinen und das ergibt
eine klebrige masse kein problem für
christina sie weiß wie man so einen teig
anpacken muss in kleinen portionen
landet alles in der heißen bratpfanne
und nach ein paar minuten sind sie
fertig die quarkkeulchen
köchin carola hat in der zwischenzeit
apfelmus gemacht
damit holte team süd auf es steht 7 zu 6
sie haben
berlin
sie nicht